[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen john early
john earlier yeah just like the word
john early yeah
i gotta tell you toots i have really
been looking forward to this
i have to say i just don't want to get
out in front of it like
i'm such a huge fan obviously your
legacy in the comedy community is
unmatched and
you never booked me i didn't take it
personally i knew that i meant it meant
that i had to try harder try harder you
know polish the act yeah well you know
life isn't a smooth road it's it's bumpy
and we're here now
and timing is everything yeah and you
know i i'm sorry if i ever said no
because right now it's just a big fat
yes
on every level
in fact let's talk you know
you weren't polished when we first
started you know when you rolled out
onto the scene
you had some you know some feelings
about what comedy was and wasn't
supposed to be where you are i get into
it right now but where did you find your
truth where did you find yourself
because you're on a real role now you're
in a real sweet spot how did you get
there mitzi i went gay i just went gay
listen i don't do straight men so this
is going to work out real well yeah hell
yeah
sexually i'm sorry i'm just confused
before we well i think sex ruins
everything so if you and i
have companionship yeah we've got it all
i love a classic kind of old hollywood
marriage of convenience you know let's
just share a bed and a kitchen and some
movie time because every time sex enters
the picture it gets the dynamic all
funny you know what i'm saying and i
don't mean the funny funny i mean the
annoying
heavy funny
i agree
so if you're open to companionship i am
okay
one thing that i really want to talk to
you about because this is something
that if you're a child actor and i was
one really oh god i've been doing the
comedy bit since i was in diapers and
that's not a euphemism
anyhow what were you in oh dog food
commercials cereal commercials you know
william hurt's daughter in uh altered
states talk about being surprised when
you see the end result
you were with a manager
as an adult that actually
was not an adult children
how'd that happen she was actually an
agent she was the only agent that came
to my comedy showcase i mean college
showcase
and
signed me because at that age you know
22 i was a little more gaunt
and she thought i could maybe like
audition for teen shows like 90210 or
you know what i mean well but all of her
clients were like five years old every
time i go in her office they were like
just a line of like five-year-olds and
their moms and then me with like newly
thinning hair okay and she always had an
open bottle of salad dressing on her
sounds like my kind of broad actually
yeah little hidden valley you know what
now where do you currently reside los
angeles what's the number one difference
between tennessee and los
angeles well there is a kind of
sunniness
you know in both places yeah kind of
smiling through the pain if you will
yeah yes it's not very mitzy yeah yeah
just with kovac careful
yeah
that way i would love if you would sound
off because i want to hear from you
about
a few things in pop culture let's sound
off i'll throw in some too so you're not
alone here let's do a start with kim and
pete you know everyone's talking about
them i'd watch
i would too right there was a shot of
her in a bikini the other day i was like
yes i am gay there's no question it was
she was so hot yeah i mean it put the
string in string bikini i was like i see
everything yeah okay and just like that
the follow-up to sex and the city well
i'm re-watching the original series
right now oh you're going back
it's heavenly i have a controversial
take as in like it's every facet of a
woman like i miss
season one season two when it's like in
the shape of the old tvs you know what i
mean right and it's like talking to the
camera and now breaking down the wall
yeah and it's so like everything now is
so widescreen to fit widescreen tvs and
i'm like i i miss the simplicity of the
box and then that brunch and like
samantha charlotte gary miranda you know
what i mean you're looking at ratio yeah
that was not what i was expecting this
interview could be at 4 3. uh
cauliflower disguised as a cob i'm so
sick of this i can't even take it what
is your take no
thank you this is just a hard no it's
it's it's
what's your binding agent you know what
i mean it's just it falls apart
cauliflower crust pizza i'm like you
mean mush i'm like oh a cauliflower
steak i'm supposed to get
about this i'm sorry i was thinking a
steak that's hell when they try to pass
off a thick slice of cauliflower give me
some a1 and a nice new york that's what
i'm looking for keep read receipts on
text messages
hostile
so
weird
so weird because here's the thing
everyone has the right we are not meant
to be this connected to this many people
at all times of the day it is so
unnatural you absolutely have the right
if you see a text that you don't want to
respond to you have the right to walk
away take a week and resp you know what
i mean
so everyone just
everyone can like what do i say to all
the leeches that are coming out of my
phone and sucking on me dry it's like oh
are you thirsty do you want the blood
i'm so sorry you reached out to me and
now i gotta bleed for you
you don't have to say anything
you don't have to say anything i think
you just you respond in your own time or
don't
so i can be absolved of the guilt by me
yeah right now
okay
this is crazy
dating apps
a necessary evil
i would say here's what i would say if
you're doing the dating apps just do the
most kind of basic kind of transactional
like thing to get you in person you know
what i mean don't i would say don't
spend too long chatting
do you think that uh there's hope
out there
yeah
yeah
i think yeah i think i did a rhetorical
question on you again
hurdling towards that okay uh the term
chugi this is one thing from the kids
that i've adopted yeah it just means you
know you're out you're uncool
it's over for you you're not on trend
you're dusty i wonder how you feel about
it but i i i feel like i'm coming into
my own chookiness and like and embracing
it if you're trying to stay cool you
know
past your 20s
you're not gonna look cool
i mean i think you're getting emotional
i just see a little well i just
appreciate it you know when when do we
stop trying i i i look at women out
there you know
licking
the salt lick of the fountain of youth
trying to tighten and i'm just like
you know
listen honey you're lucky to be alive
yeah yeah you're not pushing tulips yeah
relax
listen
i gotta tell you john i uh
i like you
uh thank you
i don't like a lot of people you know
i feel like i can be myself with you
that's uh it's again it's an honor it's
an honor having
never been booked by you it means a lot
now
well now you're booked in my bedroom if
you'd like you know what i'm still not
on stage here's what i do with everyone
can you make me do a spit take
oh that's how we end every every episode
now i'll put put it in my mouth
okay
oh no
oh no okay okay um
okay
i got it
just a classic just go physical john
john you're hired please please please
be on my stage twits it would be an
honor for me likewise john it's an
all-time pleasure it's it's been it's
been
good
it's been real good yeah all right
let's do this more often
yeah in my bedroom this has been
kibitzing with mitzi banana more i am
here
with none other than john early a real
doll thank you thank you so much wow
[Music]
you